واشهد ان لا اله الا الله واشهد ان محمدا
عبده ورسوله
اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على نبينا محمد وعلى
اله واصحابه اجمعين
اما بعد
يقول الله تعالى
في كتابه الكريم يا ايها الذين امنوا لا
يسخر قوم من قوم عسى ان يكونوا خيرا منهم
ولا نساء من نساء عسى ان يكن خيرا منهن
ولا تلمزوا انفسكم ولا تنابزوا بالالقاب
بئس الاسم الفسوق بعد الايمان ومن لم يتب
فاولئك هم الظالمون
يقول تعالى
يا ايها الذين امنوا
هذا النداء
خاطبه في القران
يدل على ان الايمان لا يكمل
الا باداء ما سياتي من امر او انتهاء عما
سياتي من نهي
مما صدر بيا ايها الذين امنوا
يعني لن يزال ايمان احدنا ناقصا
حتى
يؤدي
ما عليه من كل نداء في كتاب الله صدر بيا
ايها الذين امنوا
وهذه الايه وغيرها كثيره في كتاب الله
وهي تدل
على ان الايمان ليس مجرد التصديق
لا يكفي لاحدنا
ان ياتي بالتصديق فحسب
وهذا هو الفرق بين التصديق والايمان
فنظرنا ولاحظنا هذه
التفرقه في كتاب الله
وجدنا ان التصديق والايمان
يطلقان في كتاب الله
ويقول شيخ الاسلام وهو
تحريره وهو ما كاد ان يجمع عليه
المحققون
انه لا ترادف
في القران
تام لا يوجد هذا يعني لا يوجد في القران
كلمتين
وفيها ترادف تام
يعني هذه الكلمه وهذه الكلمه تؤدي نفس
المعنى تماما هذا لا يوجد في القران
فاذا قال الله تعالى
كلمه ايمان وكلمه تصديق
نعم الايمان هو التصديق والتصديق هو
الايمان لكن ثم فرق
دقيق في التعبير التعبيرين
مثل الريب والشك تجد كثيرا في القران
انك اذا قرات تفسيرا
ميسرا او مختصرا
اقرا في مثل قول الله تعالى ذلك الكتاب لا
ريب فيه تجد ان المفسر يقول لا ريب اي لا
شك
وهذا يسمى عند العلماء بالتفسير التقريبي
المفسر يقرب لك معنى الريب
بانه شك لكن هل في فرق بين الشك والرايب
نعم الريب زياده على الشك
بما ان الريب شك مع قلق واهميه ممكن تشك
في اي شيء لكن الريب لا يكون الا من شيء
ذي اهميه
مساله كبيره
لذلك فان كلمه الريب تطلق في لغه العرب
يراد بها الحركه والتحريك
فاذا اتيت على
مثل قول الله تعالى الذين يؤمنون بالغيب
يقول المفسر يؤمنون ان يصدقون هذا تفسير
ايش
تقريبي هو يقرب لك معنى الايمان في هذا
السياق والا فما الفرق بين التصديق
والايمان ان الايمان لا يقبل الشك
ممكن واحد يصدق اخر لكن هذا التصديق
يكون قد يكون عن غلبه ظن قد يكون عن حسن
ظن بالمصدق لكن الايمان
لا يكون الا مع انتفاء الشك تماما
لذلك
يعقوب عليه السلام
لما
جاءه ابناؤه
عشاء يبكون
وقالوا
فاكله الذئب يعني عن يوسف عليه السلام
ثم قالوا وما انت
بمؤمن لنا
ولو كنا صادقين ما قالوا بمصدق هو صدقهم
ظاهرا
قال الله المستعان على ما تصفون هو صدقهم
ظاهرا لم يكذبهم
ولكن هذا التصديق الظاهر كان ماذا
مدخولا بالشك الكبير فيما يقولون
فهم قالوا ايوه انت صدقتنا ظاهرا بس في
قلبك شيء وما انت بمؤمن لنا
فالايمان في لغه العرب يطلق ويراد به
التصديق التام الذي لا يتطرق اليه شك وهو
تصديق تام
ويطلق ويراد به التصديق ويطلق ويراد به
الايمان بما غاب عن الامور
واذا وجدت في القران غالبا
اذا عدي كلمه الايمان
بالباء فمعناه التصديق وما انت
بمؤمن واذا عدي باللام فمعناه التصديق وما
انت بمؤمن لنا لكن اذا جاء بالباء فمعناه
الايمان الشرعي
الذين يؤمنون بالغيب ولم يقل
يؤمنون للغيب قال يؤمنون بالغيب
فاذا اطلق الايمان في القران
وجاء بعده بالباء فهذا الايمان الشرعي
واذا جاء باللام ما بعده وما انت بمؤمن
لنا
يؤمن بالله ويؤمن
للمؤمنين فمعناها التصديق والايمان
بالمعنى اللغوي
الايمان
وتصديق وزياده
وهذا الايمان لا يتم بمجرد التصديق
ياتي احد ويقول نعم نحن نؤمن نحن نصدق ان
القران من عند الله
وان محمدا صلى الله عليه وسلم مرسل من عند
الله ولكن لا يقوم باي عمل
بهذا الايمان هذا لا يسمى ايمانا في
القران
هذا ليس ايمانا لان الايمان
يقتضي العمل وجوبا اذا انت امنت فعلا في
عمل يتبع هذا
فقال الله تعالى يا ايها الذين امنوا
يا من تسمى بالايمان وتحلى به
فانه لن يتم ايمان احدكم ايمان احدنا حتى
ينتهي
عن
الاستسخار من الاخر يقول لا يسخر قوم من
قوم
عسى ان يكونوا خيرا منهم وهذا زياده في
ايش
في النهي
ليس معناه التعليل
لانه لو كان معناه التعليل على
على تعريف الاصوليين
يقولون ايش العله يعني ايش عله الحكم
لماذا حكم بهذا
يقول عسى ان يكون خيرا منهم يعني مفهوم
الكلام لو انا تيقنت ان هذا الذي اريد ان
اسخر منه ليس خيرا مني فيجوز لي ان اسخر
منه لا ليس هذا هو المقصود
وانما المقصود
لا يسخر قوم من قوم وما يدريك لعل الذي
انت تسخر منه يكون خيرا منك عند الله
فهذا زياده في الردع
يقول ولا نساء من نساء
عسى ان يكن خيرا منهن
ولماذا
عبر الله سبحانه وتعالى هنا وقال لا يسخر
قوم من قوم
بدلا من لا يسخر احد من احد
الجواب
ان السخريه في لغه العرب
الامتهان
الازدراء تستحقر الاخر
والغالب في العرب
بذاك الوقت وفي هذا الوقت انهم يسخرون من
اخر
يعني اذا كان
اقل نسبا من الساخر
يسخر قوم من قوم يعني نحن خير منهم
نحن نسبنا وحسبنا كيف وكيت وهم
نكرات هكذا يعني والا فالمعنى انه لا يسخر
احد من احد
ويفهم هذا التفصيل بقوله ولا نساء من نساء
عسى ان يكون خيرا منهن
ولا تلمز انفسكم ولا تلمزوا
هذا ناهي عن اللمس
واللمس
هو المواجهه
بالامتهان
تهين الاخر
وتواجهه في ذلك
فاللمس
تحرير معنى اللمس
هو الازدراء بالكلام مواجهه
وهو الذي يسمى عند الناس في دارج اللغه
السب يعني
والتحقير والاستحقار لكنه يواجهه بذلك
هذا اسمه لمس وهو ما كان قولا باللسان
والهمس
ونفس المعنى لكنه بالاشاره
فالهمز يكون باللسان والهمز يكون بماذا
بالاشاره
الله عز وجل جمع
بينهما فقال ويل لكل همزه لمزه يعني الذي
يهين الناس
بالاشاره وبالكلمه
ويواجه الناس بذلك
وبعض الناس يقول ان اغتاب احدا
وتقول له اتقي الله يقول انا بحكي له هذا
الكلام لوجهه طيب هذا اسوا
ليست المساله مساله فقط انك تتكلم من وراء
ظهور ولكن كمان زد على ذلك انك اذا واجهت
بهذا كنت لمازا
كنت لمزه
فهو يقول ولا تلمز انفسكم ايش يعني انفسكم
هذه
هذه اللفظه فيها معاني كثيره
وفيه التفات لطيف جدا
الله عز وجل في القران
يطلق النفس
ويريد بذلك الغير
كيف يعني
قال موسى عليه السلام لقومه حينما امرهم
بالتوبه قال فتوبوا الى بريئكم
فاقتلوا انفسكم
كل العلماء كل المفسرين قاطبه اجمع ان
معنى
فاقتلوا انفسكم يعني ليقتل بعضكم بعضا ما
في واحد من المفسرين المعتضرين قال
فاقتلوا انفسكم يعني انتحروا ما قال هذا
بل المعنى
ليقتل بعضكم بعضا
لكن اطلق كلمه النفس هنا
لان
قتل الغير كقتل النفس اذا كان من المسلمين
وهذا
لتصوير الغير
من
قوم الانسان بانهم كالنفس الواحده
يقول النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم مثل
المؤمنين في توادهم وتعاطفهم كمثل الجسد
الواحد اذا اشتكى منه عضو تداعى له سائر
الجسد بالسهر والحمى ايش يعني هذا الكلام
يعني انا اذا اسات الى اخي
فكانما اسات الى نفسي
لان الامه الاسلاميه كان نفس الواحده ما
اساء لاخي اساء اليه وما افاد اخي افادني
ومنه قوله تعالى
فسلموا على انفسكم يعني ليلقي
كل منكم السلام
على اخيه
وليس معناه انك اذا دخلت بيتا ولم تجد فيه
احدا قلت السلام علي ليس هذا هو المقصود
المقصود انك اذا دخلت بيت بعد الاستئذان
فانك تسلم على
على اهل هذا البيت
وقوله تعالى ولا تلمز انفسكم يعني لا تلمز
بعضا
لا يلمس بعضكم بعضا واطلق النفس
على
الغير لانه بمنزله النفس
انا اخي بمنزله نفسي
وايضا كمان في سبب
ايش هذا السبب
يعني قول الله تعالى
فسلموا على انفسكم
انا اذا سلمت على غيري
ماذا يرد علي
يعني انا اسلم على اخوي وكل السلام عليكم
هو ماذا يقول
وعليكم السلام فهو يسلم علي صح
فانا الان تسببت في السلام على نفسي صح
ولا لا
فحينئذ
لانني كنت السبب في هذا
انزل منزله الفاعل
يعني اذا انا سلمت على غيري ورد علي
السلام من السبب في هذا الاشي انا السبب
اذا انا شرعا حكما سلمت على نفسي
ومن ذلك
قول النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
يقول
ان من اكبر الكبائر ان يصب الرجل والديه
حديث عبد الله بن عمرو في الصحيحين قال ان
من اكبر الكبائر يسب الرجل والديه
استغربوا من هذا الشيء طبعا هذا في في زمن
البراءه البشريه الان لا يستغرب ناس
بسببوا اي واحد لان الناس اصبحوا يعني في
في
فسالوه قالوا كيف يسبوا الرجل والديه قال
يسب الرجل ابا الرجل فيسب اباه ويسب امه
فيسب
فيسب امه يعني شرعا هو سب والده ليش لانه
هو كان السبب
في
جلب هذا السوء على والديه
نزل منزله ايش
السب لوالديه لانه هو تسبب لولاه سب ابو
الغيره وام الغير ما نسب والدي
وهذا نفس الشيء ولا تلمزوا انفسكم اللمس
في الاصل الازدراء وتتبع الاخطاء
فانا اذا تتبعت اخطاء الغير ماذا يصنعون
يصنع هذا الغير
تبع اخطائي فيلمزني غصبا عنه بده عدوا
فيكون كانني ماذا لمست نفسي
وهذا الشيء لا يفهمه كثير من ممن
يهين الاخرين ويستهتر بالاخرين
انت اذا قللت احترامك لغيرك وقللت الادب
مع غيرك فانه
يسخطهم والعين الساخطه لا ترى الا ماذا
الا المساوئ
انت اذا اكثرت من رمز الناس اهانه الناس
وتخطئه الناس وتتبع اخطاء الناس فانهم لن
يجدوا فيك سوى السوء الذي فيك
فبيصير اي واحد بيشوفك من كثر ما هو مليان
قلبه عليك ما بيشوف الا مساؤك
انت الذي ابديت للناس هذه المساوئ والا
فكل انسان له مساوا
نحن معذورون في هذه الاشياء التي تكون
فينا نحن بشر وكل البشر فيها اخطاء وفيه
مساوئ وفيه معايب
والمفلح منا
الذي تعد معايبه
لا يمكن لاحدنا ان تعدم معايبه المعايب لا
لا بد ان تكون موجوده لان الانسان ناقص
وخلق
فقيرا وناقصا
لكن المفلح منا
من ماذا من تعد معايبه
هذا هو المفلح هذا هو الخير بيننا
فالذي يقوم بلمز الناس يقوم الناس بماذا
بلمزه فكانه لمز نفسه
وينزل لانه السبب المباشر
فحكما هو ينزل منزله الفاعل
فقوله تعالى ولا تلمز انفسكم كانه يقول
المؤمنون امه واحده
وانت اذا لمست اخاك فانك لمست نفسك في
الحقيقه
وايضا لا تلمز الناس لالا
يلمزوك ان الناس اذا لمستهم فانهم يلمزونك
ولا يمكن لاحدنا ان يلمز اخر الا
وثم معايب ومعايب يمكن ان يعير احدنا بها
فكان الله تعالى يقول لا تؤذي اخاك لان
اذيه اخوك
كاذيه نفسك وايضا لا تلمز الناس الا يلمزك
الناس وايضا كانه يقول ايضا
انت اذا لمست غيرك لا تنسى اخطاء نفسك كل
واحد بيلمز اخوه فاخطاؤه في الغالب اكثر
مما
يعير اخيه
يعير اخاه بها
كل هذا في قوله ولا تلمز انفسكم
يقول تعالى ولا تنابزوا بالالقاب
التنابز على وزن تفاعل
والنبث
وذكر النبذ يعني ذكر معايب او اخطاء او
نقائص الغير
يقول ولا تنابزوا بالالقاب ما هو اللقب في
لغه العرب
اللقب التسميه التي يراد بها
المدح
او يراد بها الذم هذا يسمى لقبا في لغه
العرب
اللقب في لغه العرب التسميه التي يراد بها
المدح او الذم
اذا نظرنا الى القران فالقران له القاب
كثيره
القران مجيد والقران الكريم والقران عجب
والقران
هذا يراد بهذه الالقاب ماذا المدح
وايضا اللقب قد يطلق ويراد به ماذا الذم
وهذا هو المقصود هنا ولا تنابز بالالقاب
فان اللقب الذي يراد به المدح فانه جائز
لكن النبز باللقب لا يكون الا في الذم
والمقصود هنا باللقب
ما كان موضوعا
مما
يستشعر به
الملقب بالذم او بالنقص وهذا كان كثيرا
فيه وقت الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم في وقت
العرب الجاهليه وهو ايضا
دارج في في لغه العرب يعني مثلا تيجي على
بلدي فلسطين كل عيله الها لقب
دار الدب ودار ابو منكار ودار
ابو جحاش جده انا ما انا بحكي هذولا القاب
حقيقيه ودار ابو الكلبات هيك بقولوا
وهذا اذا كان لا يرضاه الملقب فانه لا
يجوز
لا يجوز وهذا من امر الجاهليه
واما اذا كان الملقب
يعني ممكن الان ممكن فيه
لقب كان من عصر جد جدي ماشي
والملقب بالعائله الملقبه بهذا اللقب الان
ليس فيه ذمه الان خلص معروفين بهذا اللقب
وهم لا يستشعرون بشيء من ذلك فهذا جائز
وهذا مما تعرف عليه العرب
لكن
اذا كان لقبا
يغضب او يحزن الملقب فانه لا يجوز
والالقاب دارجه في التعريف عند العرب حتى
في كتب العلم
يعني مثلا الغزالي
الاصل ان هذه الكلمه الغزالي من
لكنهم مشى الناس على الخطا الغزالي فخلص
صار الان الغزالي واذا قلت الغزالي ما
بيعرفوا ايش بتقول
ونفس الشيء
يقولون مثلا
البزاز البزاز يعني من البز
هذه القى وكذلك الاعمش
لابن هرمز المعروف
وكذلك الاعرج
وهذه القاب ماخوذه من
الاعمش لانه كان ضريرا يعني ما بشوف الا
كذلك
الاعرج لانه كان في مشياته عرج وهذا هو لم
يشعر بالنقيص وبذلك وجرى هذا للتعريف وكان
هذا في عصر الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم من
الصحابه من لقب هكذا
النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
كان في واحد من الصحابه معروف به
ذي اليدين كان في ايديه طوال ايديه الناس
يقولوا له ذي اليدين
والرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم سماه بذلك
قال صدقه ذو اليدين هذا ما في شيء
لكن اذا كان من اجل التنقيص او حتى اذا
كان للتعريف لكن هو لا يرضى ذلك فانه لا
يجوز
لا يجوز
وهذا هذه الايه قيل انها نزلت
لان النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم لما اتى
وهاجر الى المدينه
قال الراوي لم يجد احدا الا وله
لقبان او ثلاثه او اربعه كل واحد عنده
القاب والنبي صلى الله عليه وسلم ما يدري
مين اللي بيتحسسوا من هذا الشيء ومن اللي
راضي فكان يدعو احدهم بما يسمع من لقبه
فيقال له لا يا رسول الله ويزعل من هذا هو
يغضب من هذا فانزل الله ولا تنابزوا
بالالقاب اذا كان هو لا يرضى بهذا فانه لا
يجوز لرسول الله ان يقولها ولا لغيره خلاص
انتهوا عن هذا
فكان المستقر بين الصحابه انه لم يبقى من
الالقاب الا ما رضيه الملقب
في الابو هريره ابو هريره لقب
صحيح كونيا لكن لقب ليس عنده ابن او بنت
اسمها هريره
هذا لقب
ورضي هذا اللقب ابو هريره فاطلق عليه
الناس ابو ابو هريره حتى ان اسمه نسي اكثر
الناس لا يعلمون اسمه اصلا
واختلف العلماء ابن عبد البر ذكر اكثر من
اربعين قول للعلماء في اسم ابو هريره شو
اسم هذا الرجل اكثر الناس لا يعلمون
على كل حال نكمل غدا ان شاء الله الله
اعلم وصلى الله وسلم على نبينا